- Sometimes I just buy food and put it
in the fridge and just wait
for it to be left over.
(competitive music)
- Right off the bat, this
hot one's really good.
- Something about that cheese
is real good when it's hot.
- The cheese is never
gonna be as like gooey
and delicious as it originally was.
- Solid crust?
- Ah man, that's amazing.
That's good.
- Just like my mama
microwaved it.
- [Voiceover] This is
something that people
like almost more.
- There's just something so heart-warming
about leftover cold pizza.
- It doesn't move, which is always good.
- Okay. Alright.
- Yeah.
- It's a whole different experience.
- Like sometimes if you're feeling lazy
you just wanna open the
fridge and get something,
but this is so much more satisfying.
- I still like the cold one better.
- I like this one better.
- To me a little more flavor will hold.
That's so weird.
(dinging)
- [Voiceover] Spaghetti,
spaghetti, spaghetti.
- Yeah, it is always better a day later.
I don't know why.
- Put a little parmesan on it. Bam!
You got yourself another meal.
- [Voiceover] Who eats cold spaghetti?
That's not a thing.
- I hands down eat cold spaghetti.
- I hate this.
- Whoa.
- I think there's maybe a
texture, slimy thing happening.
- It's too cold.
- I'm okay with it.
- I don't like it.
- Well 'cause it's cold spaghetti. Duh.
- You can't skimp on the
microwave on this one.
- No.
- I'll eat your cold noodles.
- Yeah, go for it.
(dinging)
- [Voiceover] Shrimp Pad Thai.
- Hot leftover Thai is
just a familiar friend.
- Okay. Good.
- That's really great.
The microwave actually helps this.
- [Voiceover] I feel
like I might be getting
a little more flavor on the cold.
- It's kind of just dancing.
- There's a civil war
happening in your mouth.
- Not bad.
- It's not bad.
- If I have the opportunity to go two feet
to my left and put it in the microwave,
I'm definitely going to take that.
- If I had this already the night before,
I might wanna switch it up
and have cold the next day.
- You can't eat Thai food cold.
Like, we told y'all that.
- My mom told me.
- Your mom's wrong.
(dinging)
- [Voiceover] Vegetable lo mein.
- Yeah, this is good.
- This is like college.
- The heated up one's just like dry.
- They kind of just like flatten
out and you're like- (gags)
- There's no way this
can compete with this.
- Let's see though.
- [Voiceover] I think we're
gonna get into some territory
where the cold doesn't fly.
- The cold one was sloppy.
- Whoa.
- I think the cold one's
- Weird
makes it sweeter.
- I actually think I was way wrong.
It's totally fine.
- That's great.
- Whoa, my mind is blown.
- I don't know if I-
- Cold is awesome.
- This one's better 'cause it's hot.
But I see the appeal for this one too.
(dinging)
- [Voiceover] Classic.
People eat Thanksgiving
leftovers for weeks.
- Yeah.
- I mean this is the
Star Wars of leftovers.
- That's delicious.
- I love Thanksgiving so much.
- [Voiceover] Why would you
dishonor it by not reheating it?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Turkey looks daunting.
- Not bad.
- Cold mashed potatoes, totally fine.
- Are you kidding me?
What is this?
This is like a dirt clod.
- This tastes bad.
- Trying to take me to
Blandville, USA, population none.
(dinging)
- [Voiceover] Do whatever you gotta do
to eat the damn thing.
You know there's hungry people everywhere.
- We're in a very privileged position
to be sitting here arguing
about the temperature
of my leftover food
that I couldn't finish.
- [Voiceover] If you're gonna
recook it in the microwave,
you don't capture the
essence of the original meal
that was left over for you to eat.
- That logic makes no sense.
- That makes all the sense in the world.
- It does not.